في عالم التكنولوجيا اعلنت ابل رسميا عن
اغلاق خدمه تدفق الصور ماي فوتوستريم
وتوجيه المستخدمين الى استخدام خدمه صور
اي كلاود فوتوز كبديل كانت خدمه تدفق
الصور
متوفر وسيله مؤقته لتخزين الصور ومشاركتها
عبر الاجهزه المختلفه لكنها تحتوي على بعض
القيود هذه القيود كانت تتمثل في العديد
او العدد الاقصى للصور وعدم دمج صور الحيه
اللايف فوتوز كما اوضحت الشركه ان جميع
الصور التي يحتفظ بها او يحتفظ بها
مستخدمون ماي فوتوستريم سيدم سيتم
مزامنتها مع خدمه لذلك سيحصل يوم السادس
والعشرين من يونيو ستظل متاحه لمده شهر
بحيث يتمكن المستخدم خلال تلك الفتره من
تحميلها على احد اجهزته
اذا هيك خزنوا صوركم قبل ما تروح لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات